MALE SPEAKER: Welcome
to Talks at Google
in Cambridge, Massachusetts.
Today, it's my enormous pleasure
to welcome Eileen Pollack,
author of the recently
published book
"The Only Woman in the Room: Why
Science is Still a Boys' Club."
Miss Pollack is professor
of creative writing
at the University of Michigan.
She is a published author
of novels, nonfiction,
and textbooks, but she was
not always as we see her now.
At one time, she overcame
many obstacles, most of them
external, a few, if I
read the book correctly,
internal, probably, to become
one of the first two women
at Yale University to earn
a Bachelor of Science degree
in physics.
She graduated summa
cum laude with honors,
and yet chose, at that time, not
to pursue a career in physics,
which she had dreamed
of her entire life,
but rather to pursue
a career in writing.
Part of this book
is a memoir that
explains how she
got to that point
and what she did after that.
It picks up again
as a research study
sparked by Larry Summers'
infamous comment,
or famous comment, in 2005,
gee, why aren't there more women
teaching in hard sciences?
Could this be
because, et cetera.
So she took it on
herself to interview
former fellow students
and teachers and women who
had since made careers
in STEM subjects
to find out the answer.
I won't spoil it here.
There may not be a
happy ending yet,
but perhaps it's something
we can work toward.
Please, join me in
welcoming Eileen Pollock.
EILEEN POLLACK:
Thanks so much, John.
Hi, everybody.
Can you all hear me,
back rows and everything?
Thanks for coming out.
I can only imagine how busy
you all are, and it's really
an honor and it's exciting for
me to be in a Google space.
We all-- the outsiders hear how
mystical it is for you guys,
and it turns out it's true.
I've just never worked
in such a place.
But I have a lot of
attachments to Kendall Square.
So back in the
'80s, my ex-husband
was doing his M.D. PH.D.
at Harvard and MIT,
and his lab was right on the
other side of Ames street.
But of course, none of
this looked like this.
It was just this huge
wasteland, because they
were supposed to build the
Kennedy Space Center here.
So they destroyed
all the buildings.
And then Kennedy
was assassinated,
so it became the Johnson
Space Center in Houston.
And for all those many years
it was just this big, vast,
nothing here.
The only place to eat was--
there was the old B&B deli.
It's not still here.
Anyway, so it's interesting
for me to be back.
My first job was at MIT.
I worked for the head of the
civil engineering department.
He would get
assigned from the UN
to write books about
how to build low cost
housing in developing countries,
and I researched and wrote them
for him.
And considering I never
even built a bird house,
and had never been to
a developing country,
I have always hoped
that, really, nobody ever
used those books at
the UN for anything.
So what I thought I would do
was, talk a little bit more
about the book.
Because my publisher
would want me to do that.
And I do hope you'll get a copy.
And I would love to sign
them for you afterward.
And then what I'm actually
going to read to you from,
though, is a more
recent article that's
more directly focused
on tech and how
some of the issues effect
a place like, maybe Google.
So the book is divided
into a bunch of parts.
And it starts with sort of
an investigative memoir.
When Larry Summers made his
remarks, you know, I got upset,
but I had actually
known Larry for years.
We went way back.
I was a debater and high school.
I was just nerdy in every
way you could be nerdy.
And Larry was older,
so he judged our team,
and then I kept track of
him later and knew him.
So I got all upset that
he would have thought
that there was even a
possibility that one
reason there weren't more women
physics professors at Harvard
was because of any kind of
innate aptitude problems,
or that women didn't want to
work hard-- as hard as men.
The other reasons he gave
seemed to be more on target,
that they were cultural reasons,
and bias, and things like that.
So I actually sat down
to write him an email
to explain why I had really
not gone on in physics,
even though I so
passionately wanted to.
And the email just
went on and on,
and I ended up with this
like, 20 page email.
And instead of sending
it to him then,
I decided to write a book, and
then I sent the book to him
after it was done.
And he was good enough to--
there's a blurb on the back,
and he said, oh,
now I see the light
and I understand what I
didn't understand before.
So that made me feel good.
But I realized that I
really didn't understand
why I hadn't gone on.
It was so painful for me to
have worked so incredibly
hard to get that physics
degree and to do this research
and stuff, that when
I walked away from it,
I really didn't want to ever
think about the part of my life
that had wanted
to be a physicist.
And so then I had to go back
and really revisit everything.
And you know, part of it
was, as Jonathan said,
sort of these external factors.
So I went to a not very
good, rural high school.
And I actually wasn't-- we
didn't have any AP courses,
but there was a sort of
accelerated track that a couple
of boys got to take
in science and math.
And I wasn't allowed to do it
because, as the principal said,
girls don't go on in
science and math anyways,
so you would just
be wasting a seat.
And besides, it would
ruin your social life.
I didn't have a social
life, because if you're
a girl at that age,
and you're really
good at science and math,
that doesn't help, anyway.
So I got very bored, and
angry, and I stayed at home
and taught myself what I
thought were-- I was really
reading about physics, but
I thought I was actually
studying physics.
And I taught myself calculus.
But when I got to Yale, I was
just blown out of the water.
Because first of all, there
were 118 guys and two women.
And almost all of them had
gone to really good schools,
and had two years of high
school physics, two years
of advanced calculus,
and I had taught
myself this stuff from books.
So I flunked my first mid-term.
And I was going
to drop, which is
what happens to many young
women and minorities.
You get there and
realize that you
have had a terrible background,
you flunk your first test,
and of course those
courses are even
called weed out courses, right?
So there's this ethos
that if you get there
and you're not already
like, top of the pack,
you couldn't possibly
be good or worth saving,
and so let's weed out.
Luckily, I had--
you know, the book
is not a story about villains.
I know that the '70s sound
like a really long time
ago, you're mostly really young.
But it was actually-- didn't
feel much different from now
in terms of sort of
feminism and sexism.
We felt, even then, that all
the battles had been fought,
and that women
could do anything.
And I didn't feel
like a pioneer.
And I had really, really
nice-- I had all professors.
There were no women professors.
But I had really,
really nice guys
teaching me math and physics.
And so when I was going to drop,
actually, it was very unusual
but my freshman year
physics professor
wouldn't let me drop the course.
And he gave me a very good
advice, and I stuck it out,
and I worked incredibly hard.
And as often happens,
if you come from behind,
you overshoot the mark, right?
And by the time I was a
senior, I was top of my class,
and I had done
all this research.
And so the fact
that I didn't go--
and I had almost
perfect grades, but I
didn't think that I was good
enough, because no one said,
you're good at this.
No one said, are you
going to grad school?
And I thought, if I were good,
someone would have said, go on.
Which is a big difference
between most young women
the most guys, that
guys are raised more
to make their own value.
Like, not look to other people
to pat you on the head and say,
yes, you're pretty, you're
cute, you can do it, whatever.
And so women more need
this encouragement
from the outside to go on.
I didn't have confidence,
because I had come from behind,
and I still thought
of myself as behind.
If you're the only woman in
the room, the only black person
in the room, the only
whatever in the room,
there's this-- it's
called a stereotype
effect-- but this self
consciousness where everything
you do you feel like you're
representing your whole gender,
or your whole race.
You feel self conscious.
Every time I would
cross my legs in class,
even though I was
wearing jeans like,
the professor
would stop talking.
It was so distracting.
So there were just
so many distractions,
and I was so isolated, really.
All the guys did their
problem sets together,
and I was off just
working all by myself.
Nobody ever even talked
to me in classes.
And so those were the
factors that I started
to realize had really
been debilitating,
and the main reasons
that I didn't go on.
The second part
of the book was, I
wanted to see whether my
experience had been unique,
whether anybody had ever
felt anything similar.
And I was really interested in
how it compared to young women
today.
I assumed that things
really must have changed.
And so I was shocked when I--
so went back to Yale to talk
to the young women there.
I followed up with people
I had been in school with.
But I was really
interested in young women
today, and young women
at University of Michigan
where I teach, so I could
compare a public school
to an Ivy.
And I was really shocked.
There were a few more
young women in the classes.
But most of them seemed to
be saying that inside, it
felt the same as I had felt,
that they weren't getting
encouragement, they didn't
have the confidence,
they felt isolated.
But also-- I think, this it was
very hard for me to admit it,
and then I think for them
to admit it to me, too--
these beautiful, smart,
charming young women
at Yale all saying to me,
nobody wants to date us,
because when we say we're a
physics major, that's the end.
Is anybody going to marry me?
And I was like, can I really be
hearing this at Yale in 2012?
It just couldn't be.
And then they started
telling me stories
of the teasing they
had been getting like,
in junior high and high school.
You know, I'm going to
grade you on the girl
curve in your physics
class, and the boys
will be graded on the boy curve.
I mean, this is
from my childhood.
This is like, from
people your age.
Or one friend's daughter
was told by her teacher,
you're too pretty
to be good math.
And very recently I
heard-- so I heard
from one young woman who
walked into-- she wanted
to be in the robotics club.
She walked in, it
was all guys, she
turned around and walked out.
But three young women who
were in the robotics club
in high school, and they were
preparing for a competition.
The club was going to
host a competition.
And the adviser for
the robotics club
said to the three
young women, you
can be in charge
of refreshments.
So they just dropped the club.
They never told him like,
you shouldn't say that.
So this stuff was still going
on, and that really shocked me.
So I think what's different
is, there are few more women,
they last a bit longer, there
are few more organizations for
or are support
groups and things,
but I was really surprised
how little had changed.
For the third part
of the book, I
did look at the studies
that had been done
on gender bias in the science.
And more and more
of those studies
are being done now, partly
because of Larry Summers'
remarks.
So again, I think
he inadvertently
did us a real service, because a
lot of people got mad and said,
all right, he wants us to give
them the reasons for this.
Let's figure it out.
And some of the
studies we very recent,
and are really very powerful.
So the one I quoted
in the excerpt that
appeared in the Times
Magazine two years ago--
it's in the book-- by
Jo Handelsman at Yale,
which really shocked me.
So it's about implicit bias.
She ran the study at mostly
research institutions,
but one of the categories
was engineering.
So there was engineering,
physics, chemistry,
I think math was the other one.
And what they did was just
mock up job applications
for an entry level position.
So it's sort of
for someone who's
between undergrad and
thinking of one day going on
for a PH.D., and
in the meantime,
wants like, a lab manager job.
And so they're exactly
the same job application--
the same cover letter,
references, you know,
grades, everything's the same.
But one says John on
and one says Jennifer.
That's the only difference.
And if you see the bar graph
for the statistical difference,
it's so significant-- it's
not like, some little sliver,
it's huge-- that John was judged
more hireable, more competent,
and more worthy
of being mentored
than Jennifer by a huge margin.
And if Jennifer was
going to be hired,
her salary was a good $4,000
to $5,000 lower than John's.
And we're talking
really small salary.
So John would get
like $32,000 and she
was going to get $28,000,
or it's $26,000 and $30,000.
Something like that.
So that's huge, right?
And what really shocked me
was that the degree of bias
did not vary
according to gender.
So women who were going
to hire a lab manager
preferred John just
as much as guys
who were going to
hire a lab manager.
And it didn't vary by age.
So if you were an assistant
professor or a full professor,
you were 30 or you were
65, you were just as
biased against Jennifer, except
that Jennifer was much more
likely to be judged likable.
Like, who did you
think was more likable?
Jennifer.
All right?
So you can see how insidious
some of these things are.
Because if you were
Jennifer, and you went in
for the job interview,
you'd come out thinking,
they really liked me.
I got the job.
And you would even get
why you didn't get it,
because the people
hiring you wouldn't
get why you didn't get it.
So that I thought was shocking.
One study that's not
in the book that I'll
share with you that also
shocked me-- so this one
just came out,
literally, last week.
And it was done by,
actually, a friend of mine
from the old days,
Bob Sege, who's
in Boston, that came out in
the Journal of American Medical
Association.
So you tend to think, too,
that these problems aren't
as bad, say, in biology,
because those are now
women fields, and people
fields, or whatever.
So this was in
biomedical science.
And the study measured start
up grants for first time hires.
So if you-- in academia
you get your first lab,
you need money to set it
up, because you haven't been
able to get grants yet, right?
So the money comes from the
institution that hires you.
So the average
for women starting
their lab-- their support
money was $350,000.
Sounds like a lot, right?
So you could imagine a young
woman getting hired going,
wow, they hired me and
they gave me $350,000.
Yes, thank you so much.
When do I start?
What was the average for guys?
$890,000.
That's a half a million
dollars difference
to start up your first lab.
Now, imagine how
that accumulates
in terms of your whole-- right?
And nobody knows, right?
The guys don't know that
the women are being screwed,
the women don't know the
guys are getting $890,000.
It clearly has to do with--
they don't know the reasons,
because this is a new study.
But you can imagine
it might be the people
offering the money don't even
realize they're offering more
to the guy because he's a guy.
But then the guy knows to
bargain, to negotiate, right?
Well, I want even
more than that,
whereas the woman's
getting lower and going,
thank you, thank you, thank you.
So there's still
much work to be done.
The fourth part of
the book is sort
of an epilogue, in that
after the piece came out
in The Times, I got
thousands of emails,
and heard from all
sorts of people,
mostly people who agreed
about the encouragement,
the confidence factor.
And I heard more-- so I focused
the book more on, say, physics.
But I heard a lot from
people in tech and finance.
And the issue seemed
to be very similar.
I heard from women who
would say, I'd be in a room,
and I'd get an idea, or I
know how to solve the problem,
but I didn't have the confidence
to just say it right out,
and somebody else says it first.
And then I kick myself.
So that kind of thing--
the implicit bias.
And then, of course, the
issues for child care,
and how much of the
house work you're doing,
and all the benefits
for policies for taking
time off if you're having a
kid, or other family problems.
So that's the final
part of the book.
So again, rather than
read from the book,
because I'm hoping that
maybe you'll take a copy.
I thought I'd read you a
piece that I just wrote.
"The Times" wanted me to
write op-ed piece that
sort of is a new angle on this.
And so this piece
is focused more
on computer science, and
somebody else's research that
just came out.
And I don't know that I'm right.
So afterward, I would love
to hear your responses,
and if it doesn't drive
with your experience,
or it doesn't sound
right, let me know.
The largest high tech
companies, such as Google,
have finally begun to
devote serious resources
to attracting and promoting
women and minorities.
Unfortunately, if young
women and students of color
continue to shy away from
classes in computer science
and engineering,
these firms will
compete for the same
limited pool of employees
who are white or male.
Figuring out why people who
choose not to do something
choose not to do
it is like trying
to interview the elves who
live inside your refrigerator,
but only come out
when the light is off.
Women already
working at a company
might tell you what
makes them unhappy,
but these complaints
won't necessarily
pinpoint the factors
that frighten girls away
from studying computer
science in the first place.
As one of the few women
who's lived in both worlds--
I earned a Bachelor of Science
and physics from Yale in 1978
but have lived the past
35 years as a writer
and English
professor-- I've long
been interested in why women
like me who love science
and math switch to other fields,
and so many other women flee
in horror at the sight
of the simplest equation.
That young women who love
science and math grow
tired of being teased
about their interest
seems easy to understand.
Rather than receive
encouragement,
they face discouragement.
They may dislike working in a
competitive, aggressive culture
the demands they give up any
outside interests that might
keep them healthy and sane.
They face very real
difficulties trying
to raise young children
while carrying out research
that might earn them tenure.
What might strike people
as a less plausible,
is that many young women avoid
studying computer science
or engineering
simply because they
fear they won't fit in
with the students who
do take such classes.
For the past six
years, Sapna Cheryan,
who's a psychology professor at
the University of Washington,
has been studying why
girls in high school
are significantly less
likely than boys to sign up
for a class in computer
science, take the AP
exam in that subject, or express
interest in computer science
as a career, and why
female college students are
four times less likely than men
to major in computer science
or engineering even though they
test extremely well in math.
What Cheryan's research
reveals is that many girls just
don't think they would feel
comfortable in such a class.
This shouldn't be
too surprising.
When most of us are deciding
whether to move to a new town,
join a club, or
take up a hobby, we
are as perceptive as Sherlock
Holmes in picking up clues
as to whether we might belong.
Over and over, Cheryan
and her colleagues
have found that female
students are significantly more
interested enrolling
in a computer class
if they are shown a classroom,
whether virtual or real-- so
if it's for an online
class, right, the classroom,
you can make it look like
anything-- is decorated not
with Star Wars posters,
science fiction books, computer
parts, tech magazines, and boxes
for video games and software,
but rather with art and nature
posters, water bottles, coffee
makers, lamps, plants, pens,
and general interest magazines.
So one is sort of
this stereotype
of what a computer science
room is going to look like.
And the other isn't meant
to be feminine or masculine.
It's more neutral.
Interestingly, the willingness
of most male students
tends not to change
significantly,
whether they're shown
a room decorated
in a stereotypical
manner or a room
with a more neutral decor, while
about a quarter of the women
reported being drawn to the
more stereotypical setting.
So there are some women
who are like, great.
I like Star Wars.
Here I am.
The importance of what
Cheryan calls an ambient sense
of belonging proves equally
strong with female college
students considering a job
in an office that does not
conform to their image of
what a computer company might
look like.
Cheryan and her
colleagues also found
that cultural stereotypes
about computer scientists
strongly influence
young women's desire
to take classes in the field.
At a young age, girls
already hold stereotypes
of computer
scientists-- and we know
this doesn't apply to
anybody we actually
know-- as pale, awkward
young men who are socially
isolated, obsessively devoted
to playing video games,
and intensely
focused on machinery,
and whose genius is inborn
rather than the result of study
and hard work.
Given that such stereotypes run
counter to the indoctrination
most girls still receive
that they should be feminine,
whatever that means, interested
in working with other people,
and modest about
their abilities,
as well as many girls' beliefs
that they are not innately
gifted at science or math, it's
no surprise that they cannot
see themselves as happy,
successful computer scientists.
In another experiment,
Cheryan and her colleagues
arranged for female
undergraduates
to talk to an actor pretending
to be a computer science major.
If the actor wore a tee
shirt that said, "I code,
therefore I am" and claimed
to enjoy video games,
the female students
expressed less interest
in studying computer
science and less confidence
in succeeding in such a
class than if the actor wore
a solid tee shirt and claimed to
enjoy hanging out with friends,
even if the actor
was another woman.
Such stereotypes might
seem laughably outdated,
and yet studies show
that the basic stereotype
of a scientist that
most people have
hasn't changed since they
first started testing
for it in the 1950s.
And these stereotypes do still
have some basis in reality.
In some ways, young women today
might have an even harder time
imagining themselves as
physicists, engineers,
or computer scientists than
when I was a physics student
in the mid-'70s.
Back then, women
were still rebelling
against the norms of the 1950s.
Most of us wouldn't
have been caught dead
pretending to be princesses,
even when we were little girls,
or wearing high heels and
fancy dresses as adults.
We eschewed manicures,
makeup, and hair salons.
Fancy weddings that required a
year of planning were anathema.
And we weren't about
to devote every minute
to hovering over
our children the way
our stay-at-home
mothers hovered over us.
I'm not making a value
judgment about what women
should wear or shouldn't
wear, or how much time they
should or shouldn't
devote to their weddings
or their families.
But young women today
clearly face more pressure
to dress in a
feminine, sexy manner
than they did when
I was young, which
means that the gap
between the way women
see themselves-- this is
most women-- and the way
they see scientists
has only grown wider
in the past few decades, not
to mention that the messages
young women continue to receive
from their teachers, parents,
and classmates convince
them this gap is real.
For instance, one girl
I know was recently
told by her high school
teacher that she was
too pretty to be good at math.
And research demonstrates that
female undergraduates who've
watched commercials in which
women focus excessively
on their appearance demonstrate
less interest in careers
in high tech than
students who haven't
viewed such commercials.
Cheryan postulates
a similar theory
to explain why the percentage of
women studying computer science
has fallen since the mid-1980s.
Citing evidence that high
school students get their ideas
about scientists from popular
culture and the media,
she wonders if there might be a
causal link between the decline
in women's interest
in computer science
and the rise of
movies and TV shows
such as "Revenge of the
Nerds" and "The Big Bang
Theory," which portray
scientists and engineers
as white or Asian male geeks.
The media's intense focus
on the startup culture
and geniuses such as
Steve Jobs and Bill Gates
might also have inspired
more young men than women
to enter the field-- that's
her theory-- even though very
few jobs are located
in startup companies,
and very few computer scientists
are Steve Jobs or Bill Gates.
Again, present company excluded.
Some people scoff that
if young women are
going to let such nebulous
factors deter them from careers
in physics or computer
science, well,
the women are simply exercising
their own free choice.
And if girls were tough enough,
such exaggerated stereotypes
and feelings of discomfort
wouldn't discourage them.
Yet the stereotypes
are still pervasive.
Just yesterday-- well,
yesterday from when
I wrote this-- I was standing
in line at my corner pharmacy
in New York when I realized that
the covers of the magazines I'd
been staring at for
10 minutes showed
a godlike portrait
of Steve Jobs, who's
the subject of a recent
movie, at the top.
Beneath him, a big-busted model
in her underwear, then a heroic
clear-eyed portrait
of Mark Zuckerberg.
And then at the very bottom,
another scantily clad
female model.
All of us are bombarded
by such images.
How can we not absorb the lesson
that computer geniuses are men,
while the chief goal
of a woman's life
should be to look
fabulous in her underwear?
I wonder how many
young men would
choose to major in
computer science
if they suspected they
might need to carry out
their coding while sitting
in a pink cubicle decorated
with posters of
"Sex and the City"
and "Thelma and Louise" and
copies of "Vogue" and "Cosmo"
scattered around the lunchroom.
In fact, Cheryan's
research shows
that young men tend not to major
in English for the same reasons
most women don't major
in computer science.
They compare their
notions of who
they are to their
stereotypes of English majors
and decide they won't fit in.
All this meshes with
my own experience.
Even though I felt more
comfortable in a tee
shirt and jeans than a
dress or a stylish suit,
after four years of
majoring in physics at Yale,
I experienced so much pressure
to dress and act like a man
that I began to feel extremely
uncomfortable about my identity
as a woman.
Working as an intern
at Oak Ridge National
Laboratory in Tennessee,
or attending a conference
on theoretical physics
in Austin, Texas,
I felt out of place among
my mostly male colleagues
because I hated drinking
beer or eating barbecue
and didn't like getting
teased about reading novels.
I've heard similar stories
from countless women.
Even the female students at Olin
College of Engineering right
here in Massachusetts complained
to me about feeling out
of place among male classmates
who were always, quote,
"engaging in pissing contests"
or "burping the periodic
table"-- those
were their words--
or male coworkers at summer
jobs will continually cursed
and made vulgar jokes.
The good news is that womens'
stereotypes of scientists
can be surprisingly malleable.
In one experiment, young
women who read a fake article
claiming that many computer
scientists no longer fit
the geeky stereotype
demonstrated
a significantly greater
interest in computer science
than their counterparts
who read a fake article
saying that the
stereotype remains true.
To make computer science
more attractive to women,
we might try to change how
women think about themselves.
But we might also diversify
the images of scientists
that women see in the
media, along with the decor
of classrooms in which they
might want to study or work.
This would be
especially easy to do
in the case of virtual
classrooms for online courses
and the offices in which
they might apply to work.
In this way, we could
retain the men and women
who are drawn to the current
images and environments
while attracting women and
men who might previously
have shied away because they
felt they wouldn't fit in.
After all, a high tech
company isn't like the Army,
where the stereotype
of a warrior
is inextricably linked to the
actual requirements of the job.
A stylishly dressed
woman in a cheerful room
with a beautiful
painting on the wall
is just as likely to write
a brilliant line of code
as a man in an "I code,
therefore I am" tee
shirt sitting in a dingy cubicle
decorated with a Star Wars
poster and littered with
soda cans and pizza boxes.
Even small changes might
make a big difference.
A thoughtful male
computer professor
once wrote me to suggest that
changing the name of the major
from Computer Engineering to
Computer Arts, or Computer Arts
and Sciences, would double
the number of female students
overnight.
Of course, luring young
women into a field
by showing them images of
offices that don't exist
and letting them read fake
articles that claim computer
scientists are more
suave and socially adept
than they really
are might be unfair.
But as Cheryan points
out, the stereotypes
are, at best, only
partially true,
and women who actually take
classes in computer science
don't hold the
same negative views
as women who get their ideas
from movies and TV shows.
Besides, if companies
do succeed in attracting
more women and minorities,
the stereotypes
will change, as will,
presumably, the grubby decor.
Of course, as I'm
reading this to you,
I realize that this is the least
grubby decor that I have ever
seen in my life.
So that part clearly
doesn't apply to you guys.
This is why Mayor Bill
DeBlasio's recent announcement
that within 10 years, all of
New York City's public schools
must offer at least some
training in computer science
to all students is so important.
As Cheryan herself suggests,
requiring all students to take
computer science not only
would change the stereotype
as to who does or doesn't
take such classes,
it would provide girls
and students of color
with the opportunity to
experience the material
and decide for themselves
if they like the work.
At the college level,
some fairly simple changes
could allay the anxieties of
female and minority students.
At Harvey Mudd
College, strategies
such as renaming courses--
so they took Introduction
to Programming in
Java and renamed
it Creative
Approaches to Problem
Solving in Science and
Engineering using Python.
I don't know that
that's a direct--
but you can see the
difference in the kind of name
it is-- creating separate
introductory classes
for students with zero
programing experience
and students who already
know how to code,
discouraging show off
behavior, exposing students
to non-geeky
computer scientists,
and allowing them to
work on projects that
fit their preferences led to
an increase in the percentage
of computer science majors who
were female from 10% to 40%
in only four years.
So just making these
ridiculous sounding changes,
they went from 10% to 40%
female computer science majors
in four years.
As an added benefit,
Cheryan's research
on the effects of
stereotypes and what
she calls an ambient sense of
belonging on career choices
might have important
lessons to teach us
about how we might persuade
more young men to enter fields
they traditionally avoid,
such as nursing, education,
early child care, and yes, even
English and creative writing.
So that's the piece
I'm working on now.
And I would just be happy
to take questions or hearing
your disagreements,
your viewpoints.
You are the ones
working in the field.
So I would just love to
take questions or hear
what you think.
And if you have a
question, if you
could go to one of the
mics, that would be great.
AUDIENCE: So one thing I heard
as a refrain throughout that
is that if we hide
away geekiness,
then we'll attract a
more diverse culture.
And the problem with
that is that geeks exist.
And many geeks and nerdy
people and weird people
throughout high school
experience extreme--
are ostracized,
and kind of retreat
into hyper-intelligent
kind of approaches.
I don't think this
is an accident.
I don't think this is just
an arbitrary thing that
happens for no reason at all.
Those people feel very, very
invested in tech culture,
and they feel that they're being
attacked by the bullies that
bully them in high school.
Now we're all
supposed to grow up
and become adults
and realize it's
more complicated than that.
I'm not justifying
their position.
But this is a very real
conflict right now.
EILEEN POLLACK: I totally
hear what you're saying.
AUDIENCE: I think it needs
to be addressed respectfully,
and with an understanding.
So my question to you is
to answer those concerns.
EILEEN POLLACK: I think
what was in the piece
that I read was that we
need be open to more.
So we're not changing or
denigrating what is there,
we're opening to
more possibilities.
So what I was
saying is that there
are people who are nerdy, geeky,
whether by choice or that's
just who they are, or
they want to do it.
And we want to keep those
people and respect them.
So it said 25% of the women
who were surveyed actually
were drawn to the classroom
that had the Star Wars posters.
And so I was very
careful to say,
and Cheryan is very careful
to say, we want to keep that,
and respect those people.
So it's not taking
the people who
are bullying the geeky
kids, or the women who
feel that they can't show
their inner math and science
self because then they
get bullied or teased,
or nobody will ask them out.
It's trying to have
both groups now
want to be free to take
whatever kind of-- not
to be ruled by
stereotypes and bullying.
So there's this
anti-intellectual culture
that affects young men and
women who let their inner geek
and nerd out, and
they get disrespected.
But then there are these girls,
and probably some young men,
who would like to be
doing that, but they're
scared off because they've
been socialized by these images
to say, that's not me, or to
fear that if they're like that,
no one will like them or date
them, or be nice to them.
We want both of those groups.
And that was what I
kept trying to say,
is that we want to make the
images more diverse to show
more possibilities, so
we'll keep what we have now
and respect them, and draw in
people who are being scared off
by the bullying, and
by saying, but I'm
different from the kids
who, at least, have
each other in the robotics club
or the computer science lab,
but I'm not like them.
And they think that's
the only way to be.
So even though, if
you're in that room,
you feel like you're being
bullied or disrespected,
there's this other group
that's looking and saying,
at least you have an
identity and you're
doing this thing, whereas
I don't fit in with you,
and I don't fit in with them.
So it's first of
all, how do you get
rid of the awful
stereotypes from the movies
and the TV shows that are really
not doing anybody any good?
And how do you say
that there's room
for many different
kinds of people
that aren't currently in tech?
So DeBlasio saying everybody
has to take computer m at least
you then get
everybody in the room,
and there's no more sense of,
oh, only those kids do it,
or you'll be stigmatized
if you do it.
And if you do it, it's because
you have to take the class,
and then you
discover you love it.
So one way to literally
get everybody doing
and lessen the stigma is to
require everybody to do it.
The other way is for all
of us to be much more
alive to the
stereotypes, the images,
the decor, and who is
being attracted by it,
and who is being turned
off by it, and why.
And to realize that even though
it sounds like small stuff,
it's very powerful stuff.
So yeah, I totally
agree with you.
But there definitely
were lines in here
that were saying that
we want to keep--
that there are women and men
that are attracted to this.
They're great, we want to keep
them, they should be happy--
but that there are other
people that are actually
being kept away by thinking
that's the only way you have
to be.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Law and
medicine are two fields
I can think of where
there's been an increasing
number of women-- certainly not
equal yet, but much better--
and they both seem to be fairly
geeky fields in the same manner
that computer science is.
Do you have an
opinion on whether we
can learn any lessons
from those fields
and transfer them across
to sciences in general?
EILEEN POLLACK: So which
fields are you talking about?
AUDIENCE: Law and medicine.
EILEEN POLLACK: OK.
Yeah.
Great.
So yeah, I do.
So especially medicine.
What happened in medicine
is really interesting.
The big stumbling
block there used
to be medical school training.
Well, first of all,
there were rules,
and women couldn't be doctors.
They would let them
into med school.
But once they got
past that, there
were women who
wanted to be doctors,
but the training system was
a grueling hazing system
where you had to be on call
for, like, four days straight,
and you could go home.
And it was incompatible
with human life.
And especially if there
were children at home,
you couldn't just
disappear for four days,
so only men who had a
wife at home who could
stay with the kids could do it.
But it wasn't even
good for the men.
And it wasn't good
for the patients,
because a doctor who's been
up for four days straight
often screws something up.
So along about the
time my ex-husband
was in medical school, we made
it through medical school.
We made it through PhD.
We didn't make it
much past that,
because these
issues are so hard.
So he was never home.
So there was a
movement to change,
and it was partly because
women were entering the field,
and it was keeping
them out, and partly
because the men were finally
admitting that it was
destroying their lives, too.
So there was a move to humanize
medical school training so
that you didn't have to give
up your marriage, your kids,
your whole life to do it.
And that was a reason that more
women could go into the field.
They picked certain areas that
seemed more "girl friendly"
like being a pediatrician.
But you know, it's
spreading now even
to some of the more
hardcore specialties.
The reason that's
relevant is because I
think PhD training is
still a hazing like that.
It's still much more
like medical school
from the old days,
where the idea
is, if you're not
serious-- if you're not
willing to be in the
lab 24/7 and give up
every other interest, and
forget about your spouse
and any responsibilities
to any other human being,
you're not serious, you
won't be taken seriously,
and you don't belong.
And so we still
lose a lot of women.
So it's just a-- grad school's
miserable for guys, too,
but they tend to be more
socialized to tough it out.
They have to have a career.
People don't let them just
drop out as quickly and easily.
So that hazing period in a
profession tends to be a block.
And if you can get rid of that.
So I think in terms of
fields where you need a PhD,
if you can do for the
PhD program, which
is humanize it the way medical
school training was humanized,
and convince people it's not
going to lower standards--
that if you're trying to run
a program or a [INAUDIBLE]
after you've been
up for four days,
you're going to screw it up
the way you would have killed
your patient.
Now for tech, I think it's
more like what Anne Marie
Slaughter was saying
in her article, which
is just that if being
in a profession,
like that article
about, was it Amazon?
Where you just have to--
you're treated like crap
and have to work 900
hours a week-- you know,
that idea of what is needed to
be good at your field, I think,
is still something-- if
that applied to all fields,
if you can have
things more humane
and that's not the standard.
The other part of it
is the stereotypes.
So there's still this
very American idea
that somehow girl
femininity does not
equate with math,
computer, tech--
these stereotypes that girls
have picked up by second grade.
And one thing I was really
interested to discover
in researching this
book is that's not
true in every other culture.
There are a lot of
cultures where women don't
have certain other rights.
But it's inconceivable to
the men in those cultures
that women wouldn't be as good
at science, math, computer
programming, whatever, coding.
Which, if you're
American, you go, wait,
no that's such a basic
stereotype for us.
And yet in other
cultures, maybe the woman
needs her husband's permission
to go to a tech conference
because there are going
to be other men there.
But he doesn't think,
but no one thinks--
there are cultures that think
women are better at math
because women are more
creative than men.
And that whole business
about how, you know, women
used to be the software
people, because it was seen
as just the secretarial work,
until the guys decided that
was the cool part, and
then they kicked them out.
So just these-- being
alive to the hazing aspect,
the part that makes it
inhuman, but also the way
these stereotypes
are just-- I think
they're more pervasive
today than they
were when I was young.
There's even more
emphasis on women
being really
traditionally girly,
feminine, spending
all their time
on planning weddings and stuff.
And that's just
not-- and then they
get a stereotyped idea
of what tech is like,
and the two just don't mesh.
So it's being
really, really alive
to the stereotypes
that are so different.
Yeah.
You were next.
AUDIENCE: So I
don't know if you've
seen-- there's a woman online
who's known as The Geekess.
She was doing Linux
kernel programming,
and she's just
decided that she's
going to step out because
she's done with the hazing.
She's done with the
combative attitude
of having to take a lot of
crap, which, of course, speaks
to what you were just saying.
But what you're addressing
is what, I think,
we at Google tend to refer to
as the pipeline issue, where
women aren't coming in.
But there's also a substantial
issue where a lot of women,
once they're in and have
been here for awhile,
will then drop out.
I know that's something that
we've seen with the numbers
inside of Google.
I don't know if I'm
allowed to actually say
what those numbers are.
But certainly the higher
up the levels you go,
the fewer women there are.
Do you have any ideas on how
to address the lack of role
models, given that there are
few women to act as role models
for women who are
joining the field,
it's much harder to
then stick around
because you don't
have a model on which
to base what you're doing.
EILEEN POLLACK: For sure.
Well, first of all, I
focused in the book much more
on sort of the pipeline issues,
because my whole question
was, why didn't I go on?
And if I had gone on, and
I spent 10 years working
for a tech company, I
would have felt more secure
focusing on that.
I should say that
I did do-- I taught
myself Fortran when
I was an undergrad
and did a program for a
professor, a scattering
program.
We didn't have-- there were
no PCs, there were no screens,
so you had to do-- everything
came out printed on paper,
and you had to flip--
it was like a flipbook
to make the simulation work.
And then I worked at Oak Ridge
programming a simulation there.
And so I have some
sense of this.
The sexism there was
just unbelievable.
I think that was the worst
I've ever experienced.
There was stuff called
job control language,
so you needed certain codes to
even get time on the computers.
And it was run by guys
in mirrored sunglasses
who literally would
make the women say or do
something sexy and suggestive
so they could find out
that they used JCL language.
So I mean, I have
some idea of it,
but I feel like you
guys are the experts.
That said, I've talked
to a lot of women.
And I think what's really
insidious is that it's
so many relatively
small obstacles,
insults, just hardships,
no one of which
is enough to make
you just go, that's
it, that's the last straw.
But they accumulate.
And in some ways-- so
a lot of what happens
is somebody finally
can't take it, and says,
I'm just going to stay
home and raise the kids,
or I'm going to do
something different.
And then people use that to
justify that women are no good,
or that they actually
prefer something else.
So the fact that I
eventually became a writer
caused people to write
to me and say, well, see?
You preferred a people field.
I'm like, no.
It was made so miserable for me.
But it's gradual.
So the analogy I sometimes
use is if you were at the gym,
and you're on a treadmaster, and
there's a guy on the next one.
And you both think that the
incline, the resistance,
is the same.
But what you don't know is
yours is set higher, right?
And so you're both going,
and then you speed it up.
And you're sweating and
huffing and puffing,
and he's not so much, and you
think, what's wrong with me
that it's harder for me?
And he's looking over and
going, why is she sweating
and huffing and puffing?
We're both on the
same treadmill.
And then you give each
person one of those balls
at the gym that look the
same, but one's much heavier.
And you don't know yours is
heavier, because I don't know,
this data that you're not
sharing-- if everybody doesn't
know the data.
That's child care, that's parent
care, that's house care, right?
And at some point you're just
like, not only am I exhausted,
but he's not.
So I must not be
as good at this.
This isn't worth it.
I'll just go take a yoga class.
See, women just like
yoga classes, right?
So talking, registering
what's going on,
so the more that you
couldn't be aware of what's
going into the
fact that it seems
harder, to articulate
that, to bring it out,
to make as much public as
you can, to be aware of it
and to know what you're at
least experiencing and fighting,
that he got $890,000 to
set up his lab, and I got--
So the women at MIT in
the late '90s to whom this
first occurred, like, why
are we so much more tired
than the guys?
Nobody wanted to share the data.
They forced the issue.
Let's see salaries.
They were on their hands and
knees measuring lab space.
So whatever it is that
you can articulate,
I think that that's
actually even more
important than literally
having a role model.
There are a lot of guys who
are very sympathetic-- I'm
sure many of them are
in this room-- having
a sympathetic male
supervisor or role
model can be just as powerful.
And unfortunately, sometimes
it's so hard for a woman
to get to a certain point that
by the time she gets there,
she's sort of like, I did it.
I did it my way.
And it can be harder to have
her as a role model than a guy,
because she's got
so much to defend.
So I sometimes hear from women
who disagree with everything
in my book and say,
none of this is true,
because it did apply to them.
And I'm saying, right.
That's why you're the only woman
where you are, and it's great.
I love what you did.
But they're denying
that their reality--
they're saying their reality
is the same for everybody.
So it's also not
taking your role model
as, maybe, the obvious choice.
My greatest role
model as a writer
was an African American male
writer who was just brilliant,
and said everything
I needed to hear.
And he was my role model.
Whereas there were
some women writers,
older women writers,
who were-- I
don't know whether they were
trying to toughen me up,
or they forgot that at my age,
they weren't so tough either,
or that they needed
encouragement
when they were young.
So sometimes you just have to
pick different role models,
or say, oh, I can do it on my
own because-- not on my own,
but with other women at the
same level, and some men,
bring in male allies.
Just trying to articulate
some those hidden stressors
and differences, and see
if you can work on those,
rather than just let it all
accumulate the way I did,
and walk away from
it, and then be my age
and regret that you let
people-- not that it's
your weakness or your fault,
but-- if I had known what
I was coping with, I don't know
that I would have walked away.
There was another question.
We have time for-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So here I am.
I made it.
I did finish my PhD.
And I am just really fortunate.
I went to an all-girl high
school, which set me up
in college to not even-- I
really did not notice that I
was in a room full of men.
I have a very funny story
that I will spare you.
And then I was fortunate to
find a female professor who
thought highly of me
and went out of her way
to mentor not just me, but
other female scientists.
She was my PhD adviser.
And my research group
at my university,
we had parity, because
the two professors
in charge of our group
went out of their way.
But I also have friends who
are software engineers, women
who are software engineers
at other companies.
And they really do
not have a good time
in these other companies.
So I was kind of scared,
and I said, oh, thank god
I'm going to Google,
where they have
these things like
unconscious bias training,
and they care about this.
So I guess the question is,
if we are here and we made it,
what do we do to help?
I mean, I'm not going to go
and be teaching high school,
because that's not
my temperament.
But what can I realistically
do to help the women behind me?
EILEEN POLLACK: First
of all, that's great.
And I have to say that although
I don't think studies have been
done to back this up,
after just six months doing
the research on
that book, I felt
like I could tell
if a woman had gone
to an all-girl high school, or
if an African American student
had gone to a historically black
college, because was something
about that experience
of-- especially in junior
high and high school, say, in
a single-sex institution-- it's
almost like you get inoculated
against the stuff that really
was so hard for me,
needing the encouragement,
lacking the confidence.
I don't know how it weighs
out against whether there
are disadvantages of it.
But even later, when
women say then they're
in the room with
men, they just don't
seem to experience the same
psychological hindrances.
And I think that's
really important.
So with that Harvey Mudd
College, what they're
doing now, that first course,
separating people out,
so that there's
room for-- it tends
to be mostly women,
but some guys, too,
who have had no experience,
so they are not kind of
intimidated away by
the mostly guys who
feel really good
about their skills,
and are all too ready to show.
So that keeping things
separate at least long enough
that people get their legs under
them, I think, is important.
So if you're working at the
college level, that's one way.
So you're not really
separating by gender,
except it ends up being gender
influenced with the experience.
I think, really,
the work to do is
trying to-- if there are
things that work here,
trying to get other
industries to adopt, like,
what are the best practices?
Can you publish?
Can you write Op Ed pieces?
I'm the one they're asking
to write the Op Ed pieces.
If you were writing it, you'd
know even more what to say.
And then people read it and
it spreads to other companies.
And to work on these images.
Like if you're watching a
show or movie, and the imagery
of who is or isn't a
computer scientist,
or what it's like to
work in the field.
You can get people
to exert pressure,
on Facebook or wherever,
on whoever made the movie
or is selling the product.
So yeah, I think there
are things to do.
Get support groups going.
Go in to other companies to
be a role model or a mentor.
But yeah, I think
especially what
you were talking about with
the single-sex institutions,
it's very powerful.
Any other questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you
talked a lot about how
the images of who computer
scientists and programmers are
influences people's perceptions.
But has there been
any study about what
computer science is used for?
So sort of the
popular conception
of Silicon Valley disrupting
industries, and sort of it
tends to be very
aggressive language.
Does that turn off people who
just don't see what programming
could be used for that's sort
of constructive or creative
or artistic?
EILEEN POLLACK:
Yeah, very much so.
And Cheryan works on that, and
some other people have, too.
So there are two levels of that.
So the students who
are just, maybe,
thinking of going into the
field and taking a first class,
or thinking about, maybe,
do I want to major in that?
And then that-- it's extremely
important, like, well,
what would I use this for?
And basically, people
have no idea what
you do with coding,
which seems--
I know if you actually do
it, you know it's everything.
But you don't get that if
you don't know what it is.
And so one of the things
Harvey Mudd lets students do
is pick their own projects.
So that would make
it easy for you.
I mean, you're
given some guidance,
but you can pick the thing
that seems important for you
to work on.
There's some notion
that young women
want to work on people
fields or things that
will benefit humanity.
I've never really
seen a study that
proves that to my satisfaction.
And I always wonder where
that notion comes from.
I think it gets
drummed into your head,
if you're a girl,
that you should
want to work on some people
field that's good for humanity,
because I remember
people saying it to me.
Like I'd say I want
to be a physicist,
and I remember my social
studies teacher saying, no,
you should want to
work on a people field.
So where does it
really come from?
But that's a lot
of the work that's
being done with girls'
coding clubs, robotics clubs.
A lot of work is
actually being done.
It's never enough,
but they're trying
to work with like seventh and
eighth grade girls in clubs,
like, what would
you use coding for,
and is this something
that's enjoyable to you?
And it's not to blow
people's heads up
on a video game or something.
And then there's
the level at which,
once you start to be in
the culture, the aggression
and the competitiveness--
that's more the hazing stuff
that I was talking about
before, the culture.
And again, a big part of what
I'm trying to do, especially
in physics, but it's the
exact same thing here,
is change that culture,
because I just don't think it's
healthy for anybody.
And I think there are a lot of
guys who don't like it, and get
caught up in it because it's the
way they think they have to be.
So I was one of two women
who were the first graduates
with a physics degree.
The other woman became
just a whiz programmer.
I mean, she's just brilliant.
She started at Bell Labs, worked
at all these other places.
And she's been
kind of edged out.
She's currently unemployed.
And she's utterly brilliant.
But the competitive, sexist,
ageist stuff just-- she got
edged out.
So it's working on that culture
when you see it, calling it,
like, why did you have to
talk to the person that way?
Or if somebody
presents something,
do you have to
jump on them first?
Could you maybe say what
was good about what they did
before you make suggestions?
That's the difference.
One last thing is, one
thing that struck me.
So Dropbox was trying to
recruit more minority employees.
And they had one African
American engineer
who was pretty high up.
And he went-- I don't know
if it was his alma mater.
He just decided to go to, I
think it was Howard University.
And he said, how many
of you use Dropbox?
And a lot of them raised their
hands, because a lot of us
use Dropbox.
He said, well, wouldn't
you like to come work
for the company that
makes this happen?
And they're like,
yeah, we really would.
Would you like us to come?
Because nobody's ever
recruited anybody here,
and we'd love to do this.
Part of it was they didn't know,
oh, yeah, I use this thing.
It would be fun to
create stuff like this.
So that's part of it,
knowing what you do with it.
But also thinking you're
wanted, because you
look at the room, or the
movie, or the whatever,
and there's nobody who
looks like you there,
and nobody's coming to
your school to recruit.
So yeah, all of the above.
What are you going
to do with this?
And I think what happens is,
once you're in the field,
it's so obvious to
you that to get back
down to the level of an eighth
grade girl or an eighth grade
boy, or an African American
kid-- you know, why is it
not obvious to them?
Where was it that you
picked up the ideas,
and how are these people either
being welcomed or scared away?
That's sort of where it is.
I think that I'm being signaled
that we have our time up.
So I will stick around
as long as you'd like me,
if anybody wants the book.
But thanks so much
for inviting me.
I really am glad I
got to meet you guys.
[APPLAUSE]